i want to bring up this uh this tweet
here
it's from me
there's a tweet from stonewall jackson i
responded to where he says this is so
pathetic the new star trek show depicts
what appears to be the january 6 protest
leading to the end of the world and the
human race as we know it i actually
i i find the clip from the new star trek
show very interesting they called
january 6th a fight for freedom
yeah no no
so um i don't know if we can play it
because you know they're very litigious
here on youtube but he says it started
with a fight for freedom
shows audit the vote on january 6 and
then the protests from the summer and he
says it ultimately led to the eugenics
war
and then finally world war three where
hundreds of thousands of species were
wiped out but hold on there a minute is
that not plausible
it starts with a fight for freedom so
they describe january 6 they show kind
of crazy they would call january 6 a
fight for freedom but sure
led to the eugenics wars well hold on
what's happening right now roe v wade is
being banned and the left is going to
the homes of supreme court justices and
they've thrown there's an uh on a
non-profit pro-life non-profit had a
malta cocktail thrown through its window
reportedly that's the accusation and
several pro-life pregnancy centers were
vandalized
in this
show or maybe they didn't realize it
it makes sense plausible
in today's day and age are eugenics war
yeah the abortion issue i think it's
kind of poorly written because if there
was really because then they go it led
to the uh which led to civil war which
then led to
war well he says ultimately world war ii
ultimately world war three what he would
really be saying is then china and the
united states and he talked about world
war i the stuff leading up to it is
forgotten well no no hold on i think
this actually works let me break it down
for you political crap you've got
january 6 a fight for freedom as he
calls it you then have you know people
are fighting tensions are rising roe v
wade gets overturned and then all of a
sudden you have blue states outright
saying abortion even in virginia after
birth and and the media will claim it's
not true but we all heard what northam
said the baby would be delivered
resuscitated if that's what they wanted
and kept comfortable and then the
conversation would happen which
basically means what fine what's the
conversation about
let's just say well he wasn't specific
colorado limitless no restricted
abortion could this lead to a conflict
which is about whether or not some
people should not have kids or or should
it's happening how could how could it
then become world war three he may be
oversimplifying it but the political
conflict inside the united states could
ultimately result in a unipolar world
destabilizing china expanding in various
countries russia expanding in eastern
europe the u.s still trying to main
maintain unipolar dominance and then
world war iii i think it's fascinating
they wrote this through it but i will
start with the point where they describe
january 6 as a fight for freedom yeah i
think what and i'm sure you know this i
appreciate your analysis but obviously
they were trying to smear the right more
or less put it on conservatives i i i no
no i really don't think so you think
they're trying to be neutral in what way
could you could you he literally shows
january 6th as a fight for freedom how
could you in any way say he's trying to
smear them well i think when you look at
the track record of hollywood and their
analysis of current events they tend to
come down on the side of the left and i
would also argue that for a television
show to explicitly say they were in
favor of what happened on january 6
would basically be suicide you would
have said it started with disinformation
riling up
disaffected citizens into believing
their country was stolen from them and
rioting which sparked a civil war no he
said a fight for free january 6 wasn't a
fight there was a few people that got
into it maybe but it wasn't it was just
a protest maybe he was talking about the
feds and he's like those feds were
fighting for freedom it does then show
summer of love stuff
you know so yeah so also it's possible
you know they write the dialogue and
then the editor ends up placing certain
images over the dialogue that the writer
might not have intended but you know i
kind of i think i agree with you ian
about the point that it's a little bit
lazy so it's not abnormal for a science
fiction show about the future to comment
on current events or at least
contemporary culture but to do it in a
really over-the-top way like this seems
really lazy instead of the crazy instead
of creating an allegory for it or having
characters in the future present a
situation you might be more detached
from than the current event they are
literally showing things that happened
today and commenting on it i think it's
a rip off of a star trek episode where
data asks about terrorism
because they're they visit a planet
where there are terrorists and then he
mentions data says i don't understand
some elements of their conduct you know
we say it's wrong to do these things but
it's actually been quite successful for
many groups and then he mentions mexico
ireland and then he mentions a
fictitious 2020 you know 20 20 22 or 22
20 something event star trek world
and
basically what that data does is he asks
a question about
uh terrorism
using real historical elements and then
a fictitious sci-fi element from the
future we haven't encountered yet it
seems to be the exact same thing they're
doing it's lazy it's very lazy it's
video footage from last year too
which is that's why i watch star trek
that's why i watch sci-fi shows about
the future i want to see video footage
from last year yeah right
laziness no but i don't know i find it
fascinating i wonder i you know
laziness or short-sightedness or like a
lack of creativity on the the
or a political underhanded move yeah i
don't think you can i mean
i haven't seen the clip but i don't
think you can put a january 6 clip in
that context on a show without it being
a political decision i mean i think
that's something that's done on purpose
yeah
absolutely well that also shows it shows
that george floyd's right right okay yes
well but and of course this kind of
thing affects re-watchability like if
you you know people will go back and
re-watch episodes of tng or the original
series and
i don't think i really don't think
people are going to be going back and
rewatching this 15 20 years from now not
i i'm not watching it the first time
yeah exactly exactly they they've
they've just
you know what it is i don't i don't know
they hired a bunch of people who hate
star trek to write star trek is this the
one with stacey abrams she made an
appearance as like the president of the
planets or something did you guys that
was discovery i think
stacey abrams the the president of earth
okay political star trek trash again
they have a politician as a character
you know you mentioned this earlier we
were talking before the show about the
late night tv
and how their uh in the key demo we
actually rival some late night
television shows which is actually
really bad for them because they used to
get 20 million views and the funny thing
is you mentioned how
older people watch those shows they used
to watch it every night but now they're
being made fun of
this is the funny thing like jimmy
kimmel for instance in like the late
night the people who are who are
watching cnn the people who are watching
these shows the overall majority are
like 60 to 70 years old
and they're trying to make the politics
of these shows fit a millennial leftist
or progressive world view and it's like
well that's not the boomer generation
so
your show used to actually attract tens
of millions of people in the boomer
generation you've decided to sacrifice
all of that
for millennials who consume digital
media they should just be making a new
show
they should keep that show with older
hosts to keep talking to the older crowd
that was young in the 80s when david
letterman was in his 30s and then they
should have a news show but they're
competing for time slots which is also
archaic because people watch stuff on
youtube at any time of day you don't
need it stuff's on demand now it's
people industry i don't know i i don't
want to make a generalization of
industry being slow to adopt the hot new
thing but the entertainment industry
sure is it's they were still making me
mail headshots in in like 2008 to uh
because sending a digital thing was
apparently just it was they just didn't
under it was too new so it wasn't good
are we just uh going through the natural
progression of old fogiaism where we're
like it was better when i was a kid yeah
i mean i'm 27 but i'm already there you
continent
continental
i did hear you say these kids today
remember i remember uh
the simpsons thing where abe was talking
to a young homer and he's like it'll
happen to you too
i used to be with it but then they
changed what it was not what it is is
scary to me i think it'll happen to you
i think children today are smarter than
the previous generation um
intellectually and their minds work
quicker but and that's the natural
progression of evolution but emotionally
we're experiencing some challenges
because of the disconnectedness of the
technology you know what i you know i
was thinking though i i wonder if that's
that's true because i know kids today
are still very much passionate about
capturing small animals and forcing them
to fight each other yeah yeah it's
really beautiful i went to i went to a
we went to a bowling alley arcade the
other day and all the kids just love
forcing animals to fight you know
brutally just beat each other and uh
tons of pokemon toys everywhere yeah you
know i grew up i grew up with pokemon i
remember when the when it i guess it
first started the like in in america and
i bought pokemon red on the original
game boy with money i made at my
family's cafe from tips and uh today
kids are still very much watching
pokemon and the toys are like the big
prize at the arcade were pokemon stuff
i was talking to somebody like i guess a
couple months ago now
did you know there are pokemon cards
that get sold for a half a million
dollars yes
garyvee is a big proponent he had to
show me on his phone i did not believe
him
the funny thing is like
having owned so many foil first edition
pokemon cards and then just like having
lost them or sold them painful now it's
it's like a laughable when i'm like
that's how much they're going for these
days wow because the printing run was so
low i don't know because look you know
millennials are broke right
millennials are are relatively poor so
so who cares that much about pokemon
other than nostalgic millennials so i
guess there's a spattering of wealthy
millennials who are like
i would like to buy a charizard for a
million bucks it's got to just be
speculators in the market right i don't
think it's like a pokemon fan who's like
i've got to have that car there's some
dude who's like there's like a gen z i
mean he mowed a lot of lawns that summer
and he needed that pokemon card no no
think about it if you're if you're gen z
right now
it is a great bet to buy old pokemon
cards because once the boomers
age out and then millennials inherit a
lot of this wealth you're gonna have a
bunch of nostalgic rich 60 old
millennials and you're going to be in
your mid 40s and you're going to be like
you want that charizard i got it and
that 100 000 is going to be 10. thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there